hey good afternoon everybody it's mike
from order flows and i'm glad you're
able to come today's special workshop
with my good friend aaron corbs and you
know we got a lot of stuff planned for
you aaron is a guru on
volume profile and you know volume
profile and order flow sort of go hand
in hand and what i like about volume
profile is it gives me sort of a longer
term view of the market because you know
i'm more of a really short-term scalper
and i'm trying to slowly move away from
that and get into a longer
view of the market and you know aaron is
a great teacher i've learned a lot from
him you know people like oh mike you
know why you watch other people and you
know because i'm always trying to learn
and to be honest it's
introducing
you guys to somebody else you know i'm
very guarded about that you know it's
not just
anybody that i want to introduce you to
i want to introduce you to people that
i feel you could really get value from
and learn from
and
you know aaron is one of those guys so
you know before we jump in you know just
a brief disclaimer you know we're all
adults here we all understand
that trading involves risk okay so yeah
i'm not going to try and sugarcoat it to
you and you know let's tell you you're
going to go out and buy a lamborghini
next week
with your training profits it just
doesn't work that way that's not how
life is so
if you're wondering who aaron corbs is
now i know a lot of you are familiar
with them but some of you are not
he's
been trading with volume profile for
quite a while he does have a youtube
channel so if you haven't you know if
you want to do a little bit of your you
know your own research on him and go
down there you can see you know he's
he's
got good following on youtube i mean he
even posts you know his trades and he
explains them um you know he helps
traders
basically become profitable which is
what you want to do as a trader
and he's also got his podcast
speculators podcast so you know he's a
great person that you can learn from and
that's really what we want to do as
traders we always want to be learning
and improving our craft you know i
always say trading is a journey
you don't reach the final destination
it's not like you you reach a level and
that's it you know you always got to be
honest changing with the times but you
know adapting to the times because the
markets are dynamic the markets are
always changing and you know people
and i've always found people to be a bit
cynical when it comes to learning how to
trade you know people say well if you
have something that works you know why
share it well it's not like
you get to that certain level the level
of profitability as a trader and
to let somebody else up somebody else
has to come down no there's plenty of
room for everybody you know at that
level where we could all be profitable
it's you know i'm a big believer in you
know sharing the knowledge and and
helping other people's get up there
because again you know it's not like you
become good at something a successful
trader making consistent profits that
you know if a person another person
comes up to that level you're going to
go down no there's there's plenty of
room up there for everybody
so
with that i'll turn it over to aaron um
and aaron i want you to give the people
that aren't familiar with you you know a
bit of your background and for how you
got into volume profile
awesome i just muted myself can you hear
me yep it sounds good
oh very cool very cool uh great to see
you again mike and appreciate being on
appreciate the opportunity i know we're
a little crunched for time today which
is great and um so i'll try not to
stretch anything out too long but yeah
if anybody's here and they don't know me
or they're not familiar with my story at
all um mike covered a little bit about
it but i got back or i got into trading
back in 2013 the very end of it uh into
and i love the topic we're talking about
today we're just gonna be looking at
some very tactical things about the
volume profile trading in general has a
very special place in my heart and
specifically the volume profile
when i got into trading it was
very much a time in my life where i was
early 20s fast approaching my mid-20s
and kind of in a unique space where i
didn't have a lot of things going on in
the sense that i had no college
education at that point or even still
through today i didn't have a high
school diploma
and there was very little options as far
as what my path forward looked like and
so on the path of kind of exploring some
things i found myself into my way into
trading and what it has done for me and
what has allowed me to do
it it's truly amazing and i have a
strong passion for this as a business
for building this skill set for
continuing to improve upon it
and then at the core of everything i do
is the volume profile so fast forward
through today
um what we're gonna be looking at and
kind of jumping into this part of the
session
is
this week and kind of in the most recent
action we're just going to be looking at
some very specific
examples of how i'm using the volume
profile and how i'm able to um
identify certain patterns that that are
profitable i want to share those with
you so that you can start looking into
them as well kind of an interesting time
to be doing this because we are as mike
mentioned uh
i have a youtube channel and we're
actually trading live in the mornings on
that youtube channel right now so even
some of these examples we're going to go
through and kind of look at these
entries and and look at how things
shaped up on a bit of a static chart uh
if you're up for it and you don't mind
digging around a little bit you can
actually go back and watch these in real
time and see how these are executed
which is is kind of a uh a cool you know
piece of it there i'm sure um as far as
the background goes mike is there
anything else to cover or should we
press on no that's fine uh what time do
you trade live there do you stream it
like at uh in the morning or it's like 8
a.m to 10 a.m or something like that
right
yeah exactly so it tuesday wednesdays
and thursdays we'll go live at eastern
time 9 30. and then we'll just trade
until the main ideas have played out and
until we're just waiting for the next
phase and then in on friday excuse me on
mondays we go live in the afternoons at
2pm okay and then friday there's no
stream that's just where i'll trade by
myself and and uh we won't stream that
live
yeah cause i've watched your replays and
i say i haven't attended like the live
stream so you know maybe i'll pop in and
troll you but
i'd love to see it that would be awesome
all right let me turn the screen over to
you um
okay great
give me a sec just so i'm aware as well
is there an option as we're going
through this to kind of interact and do
um let's say the chat box and all of
that live or is this something that i'm
not going to be able to see on my side
yeah there's um
there's questions i'm keeping an eye on
them so if there's something comes up i
might just just jump in and and and say
it so i'll be a bit like the moderator
okay great so yeah so go ahead you know
i i really want to hear what you got to
say i'm sure everybody else is very
interested
oh very cool very cool okay um i know we
don't have any video going so you just
should be just seeing my screens mike
you can probably just confirm that
you're looking at uh uh current price at
least at 41.45
on the chart
yes i see the chart there with the
profile in the middle
yes yes yes very good okay great um let
me just say by way of a couple
introductory thoughts as we get into
this my understanding and the people in
this room and anybody listening to this
on a replay
we are not uh beginners to the volume
profile and
this i kind of structured this in a way
to be a little bit more advanced and not
not start or not to cover some of the
basic things like auction market theory
and
i'm assuming that we know these things
um if that assumption is wrong the rest
of this talk might be a little over
everybody said but uh i don't think it i
know that's where we're at on this um
and so
by way of introduction though as we
start to look at this i would like to
say a couple ideas about how i'm using
the volume profile just so we have that
as a reference because how we're using
the profile what the profile is good for
how the the volume profile is powerful
um
these answers can change and there can
be definitely more than one answer to
this but as far as what i'm doing here
one of the core ways that i'm using the
volume profile is a unique way to look
at structure
inside of
the market look at the action and to be
able to identify in a pretty unique
visual way
repeatable patterns in the market not so
much head and shoulders or or double
tops and double bottoms but still
very repeatable patterns that surface
and then as we get to identify these and
as we become familiar with them um we
can look to put together very high
quality trade ideas that do give us edge
and that give us a likely understanding
of at least what's likely to happen next
now with that being said when we are
looking at the volume profile there's a
very
or i should say it like this the volume
profile is on the analysis side of the
business here and as a trader we
obviously do our analysis whatever form
that comes in but the difference between
analysis and trading is very dramatic
and it's easy to look at something like
the volume profile to feel like you
understand it
and then to to
fall under the illusion that now that's
automatically going to translate into
profitable trades or into large sums of
money
and
the reality is that we need the analysis
but there also has to be additional
skill sets drilling into that and
understanding how to interact with the
market how to pull the trigger how to
manage those positions um
these things combined with our analysis
make up the entire you know something
more of a holistic approach and um
a lot of people especially traders are
very good at analysis but being able to
spot what is likely to happen and then
actually being able to execute on that
and to pull something from the market
are entirely different skill sets what
we're focusing on right now this is
going to be more on the volume profile
analysis side of things but i think it
should be stated that way we're not
putting
an unnecessary amount of importance on
this one facet and understanding that we
need to incorporate these other things
as well
the other thing i'd like to say by way
of introduction and this is very
important for the the month that we've
been in right now
is there will be times when you are
using an approach where that approach is
and the edge that you're using that for
cycles in and out of favor i think this
is something that we all understand but
we we are seeing a little bit of this
happening right now so i did want to
stress this
with a lot of the fundamental news that
we are just being bombarded with where
you know this week we have the jackson
hole thing going on the week before that
we were dealing with the fomc minutes
being released the week before that
inflation data midweek the week before
that was the fomc meeting midweek uh the
kind of environment we're in it just
seems like each and every week towards
the middle of the week lately there's
there's been large news events
the the volume profile is very much a
technical analysis type of an approach
here and when there are outside forces
that are
pushing us around strictly on
fundamental type news related events
this is one of those environments where
the profile's edge will be weakened and
we get a little bit sloppier action
around levels that we would expect to be
a little
more defined
now the important thing to understand
about this
is
uh as we're going through and as we're
as we're using the volume profile um
being able to identify when your method
is being less favorable and when your
edge is being stronger
this would be an important skill set an
important part of knowing your method
well
an important part of not not getting um
understanding how to move in certain
environments and we'll look at some
specific examples today of exactly what
i mean by that all right and as we jump
into it if i could maybe say one more
thing just by way of uh laying the
foundation for some of how i'm
interacting with the profile and what it
means to me
whenever we're looking at information
on something on the profile whether it's
a value area high a point of control
something along these lines
much more important than what we are
looking at is how it got there so if
we're looking at an lvn for instance
lvns are important but more important
than there's an lvn here
is how did the lvn get there and what
that means is context and if we ever
lose that amount of context it's easy
depending on how you were introduced to
trading especially if you were
introduced to trading in a very um
indicator based strategy
it's easy to try to fit the profile into
a buy here sell here system and that's
not what this is
to trade the profile well it does
require that we have uh the ability to
look at these things to understand that
they are there and to be able to think
through things at a little bit of a
deeper level than just
i'm at an lvn so this means i need to
buy or this means i need to sell there's
additional thoughts that really need to
be put into place when we're when we're
talking and when we're looking at the
volume profile okay
so hope some of those things make sense
and i think that'll help serve us paint
a little bit of a picture here as we're
diving into some very specific uh trades
and some very very specific action
all right let's jump into the charts um
and then any part any kind of path along
this way
um
mike i'll say
i'm not really stuck into any type of
format so you're not going to throw me
off if you want to jump in and ask a
question
you know yeah no it's i got nothing to
say so far i mean it's it's great i mean
what you say is you know identifying
when
your edge is getting stronger or weaker
you know sort of one to stay out of the
market is is important um
i'm always stressing that you know so go
for it
great okay what we're looking at right
now is the s p this is um this is
tuesday i believe it was actually this
tuesday um and again this is one of
these sessions you can go back you could
actually watch what we're gonna talk
through here and you can watch and see
how that played out in real time
the first
uh
pattern that i want to talk to you all
about have to deal with
double distributions this is one of the
most recognizable profile shapes um this
is
a very repeatable thing that we'll see
happen so what we're stressing here is
the double distribution
and we're stressing this is the
following day and this is where we're
going to look at how exactly this
information turned into trade ideas
but very quickly i think most of us will
be aware of what double distributions
are a double distribution is when the
market spends some time trading a good
amount of volume building out a
distribution like we see on top
and then there's something that drives
us into a different area where we spend
a lot of time we trade a lot of volume
and we build up a new distribution these
two distributions get separated by an a
low volume area and it creates a unique
double distribution
type of shape
this and everything we're going to talk
about today are are fairly unique
visuals that if you're not looking at a
volume profile i don't know of another
way to really see
where these lvns show up where those
distributions are uh these things become
very very important to the process
so we're looking at these double distr
this double distribution right now
um and the idea is this when we see a
double distribution the following day
the the cutoff point between these two
distributions creates very nice trade
opportunities
if we are in a situation where we open
up as we did in the lower distribution
as long as we were are holding on to
that lvn and as long as we were holding
on to this lower distribution
the pattern would be to expect that
we're going to be spending more time on
this lower distribution and heading
still in that direction
now if we are unable to hold this lower
distribution if we are unable to hold
the lvn
then looking for us to revisit the other
distribution on the day
is very likely
and an amazing target would be the point
of control for the other distribution or
uh the the hvn on this other
distribution as it were okay so these
are these this is the general idea here
and coming into the session where we
opened down here at the 37
that was part of my primary idea that if
we can test and hold this lower
distribution i'm looking to get short
into this lvn i would like to move this
down looking for new low of day i had
actually an additional target down here
in the 20s
and then if we were able to break above
this lvn i'm looking for us to target
and to reach this 4160 area which is
going to be the other side and the point
of control of this distribution
now uh the way that this ended up trade
playing out i can turn on my trades here
we opened up we started this push higher
and as we pushed into this lvn hit the
short
i grabbed short took off a scale to
secure pro to help mitigate the risk on
this trade
took off another take profit as we
pushed into the point of control of this
distribution and then was looking to
hold this until new low of day and then
wanted to see us uh even work our way
down further into the 20s what ended up
happening is we pushed through the low
of day by one tick
this was right at 9 45
when we had some news hit tuesday at 9
45 we had some news hit you can't really
see through this static chart but the
market absolutely went mental right here
just just started really freaking out so
as that freakout happened i hit the exit
uh bailed on this trade idea sat through
all of this rotation just trying to
figure out what exactly was going on
with uh with the day here
we ended up
busting through going coast to coast
putting in a new high
and then as we tested this lvn from the
other side i got long
looking for this to
make a return
to the other side of this
the other side of this um distribution
and to visit that point of control
now
entered the trade
hit a scale out and then also right in
this time this was right about 10
o'clock
and we also had some more news coming
out at 10 o'clock and so as we're
looking at just these recent examples of
trades this is what it looks like in the
dirt of trading every day we don't
always get clean unadulterated moves
most of the time we have to be dealing
with something that that's causing a bit
of frustrations for us so i entered the
trade scaled out to mitigate risk we
ended up just stalling out here for
several minutes the news event was
getting ready to hit uh i was hoping
best case scenario we kind of pushed
into the news and then maybe popped on
the news no such luck
as we were just stalling out i went
ahead and locked in a little extra just
to mitigate the risk i thought the
likelihood of me getting chopped out was
fairly high
we ended up dropping this is where the
news came out we kind of had a little
bit of ruckus on that news and then just
blasted straight to the other side of
this distribution
now
rather unfortunate the way this shaped
up because as we pushed through the
first time we pulled back very nice i
got myself an entry and looked for that
continuation it didn't happen the second
time we broke through we just went
straight to the other side and there was
no option for me to re-enter on that
um this is a nice example of what i was
saying earlier the difference between
analysis and trading to know that if we
break above this we're likely to revisit
this other distribution that's part of
analysis and that can give us some very
powerful information
but to be able to pull the trigger and
actually take advantage of that trade
is a very different thing and this is a
perfect example of of falling short of
being able to do that now
there was outside forces and um you know
some things that caused me to do that i
don't wouldn't necessarily just chalk
this up to bad management also a little
unfortunate that there was no re-entry
uh as it you know went through the other
way but
so this is that double distribution and
whenever we see this pattern it's fairly
repeatable the next day it typically is
going to create some very very nice
opportunities for us uh for the exact
things that i just mentioned okay
probably all i have to say about that
unless there's some type of a dialogue
so i'll just plan on moving on unless
you want to stop me mike yeah no that's
fine um that's fascinating um
one question though uh somebody asked
uh
what is ldn
did you say ldn or you say hbn
yes yes i was saying
um
larry victor nick
low volume yeah yeah low volume node
that's the low volume area right right
okay yeah
got it that's what i thought but the
question was ldn so i figured maybe
your words you're you know sometimes
when you people hear things they they
hear it a little bit differently one
other question
so your profile your double distribution
is from the previous day's cash session
yes excellent question okay yeah
starting at 9 30 a.m eastern time ending
at 5 p.m eastern time okay one of the
questions what time frame are you using
is like a one minute chart five minute
chart
or yep so um important to note whatever
you put the time frame to it's not going
to affect the actual profile the profile
isn't based on time um but this is going
to be a trigger chart that is set it's a
pnf and it's set to 1-11.
so point and figure
yeah it's a point figure
instead of having x's and the o's i
switch it to candles it's just i learned
on candles and i can't really adjust
anything else well so
um yeah looking at the candles
and
the the the reason that i'll do this is
this is very noisy and granular in
details
but this allows me
um to see
very detailed information so if you're
just looking at this for instance this
push up
that you know pulled back and moved
higher this might just be one candle but
because it's so noisy i get to see like
this little pullback that retested that
gave me the entry
uh not very many time-based charts are
going to allow me to see that type of
rotational information
and so for that i don't really like to
use a time-based chart for my trigger
chart i like it to be something based on
just the action okay fair enough fair
enough yep let's go on to the next
next one
okay let me
switch
my
charts around
and
okay got it great oh um okay i have a
few to cycle through here so let me
uh i like
this one should be nice
okay
okay what we're looking at here is uh
and i'll just kind of confirm that
there's says 46 up here in the corner
and everything switched yeah
yeah it did come up uh
it says 46 yeah
right yep good to go
okay what we're looking at here is um a
fairly unique day on the s p this
happened uh a couple fridays ago and
i'll i'll i would actually be very
interested if anybody knows the s p well
and can look at how this shaped up and
understand
just by looking at it if you're able to
pinpoint why it's
odd and why this is a very unique thing
that we hardly ever see
i won't like belabor it i'll just keep
talking but if anybody answers it i'd be
interested uh if anybody has an answer
for it
so
um what we're looking at here though is
the s p opened up here's the open way
down here it was actually quite a large
gap that we opened in and this action
just absolutely took off looking like
driving type of behavior
um setting up to be a trend type of day
and there's a few things understanding
how the market opens and being able to
put together what exactly the opening
type is
that can cue us into this
some surface level things but when we
open and immediately get big moves off
the open that's a very early sign that i
don't want to fight this immediately
potentially i just want to be looking at
joining this
another thing that is a repeatable
pattern nothing to do with the volume
profile but if i can actually turn these
trades on
this is a trade idea that i took it's
actually not what we're going to focus
on um i want to focus on something
different but
uh typically if i can identify very
early that it looks like we're shaping
up to be a trend so big powerful moves
right off the open
very common to almost have like two
pullbacks to the v-wap
very early in that move and you'll
notice this if you look at the s p and
you see trending type behavior if you're
looking at just the daily v web some
version a lot of times it's like a test
with a slight break or a slight break
and then kind of a second test in this
case kind of a missed it by a little
tested it to about the tick
anyway when i can just put together that
that double kind of
dip is happening on that second test it
creates very good risk to reward because
if it starts breaking down v wap i
understand that okay that entry didn't
work and if we hold v
i'm expecting that this has the
potential to be a trend day where i
would look for the initial balance to be
set us to break through the initial
balance go for range extension um so it
creates uh not a lot of information for
a trade the quality of the information
is quite low but the the
what you sacrifice in
knowing very little
you get rewarded with with extreme
potential and similarly like we see here
a lot of times if we open up and start
driving the market just goes and the the
pullback you're waiting for never
happens so in that environment uh i find
the the being a little bit aggressive
can also pay off very very well
so this is something that shaped up and
happened now
what i want to point to just real quick
so that magenta line is the days view
app
this is the dailyvee app yes okay got it
yeah very important level
um for me it's also uh most everybody
has their eye at the on v web at some
level so it's a it's a very nice thing
to make sure you you look at got it
so what we'll just kind of look at here
i'm going to
draw a volume profile because we can't
see this information with the completed
profile we need to kind of see how this
is developing so this is the same
information we're looking at here it's
just a heat map instead of
you know kind of the traditional look
that i have well evaluary low we have
value area high and then this is the
point of control okay so same
information we see here it's just
displayed a little different
now
what we'll notice is as um
as price is here the point of control is
here
as price keeps climbing up
um the point of control shifts higher
and then the point of control shifts
higher again
this is also very normal to see when we
are shaping up to be a trend the profile
can actually help us put that together
when we see an elongated profile that's
looking very jagged separated by these
kind of lower volume areas and then as
we pause for moments we bulk up new
volume
and then we just keep going again a lot
to support the idea here that this is
turning into a trend
now
what ended up happening and this is
something that again i think we only see
on the volume profile that should not
happen
if we're having a good strong trend
is the point of control shifting up as
we go
and then as we pull back
the point of control
shifting lower
something is very wrong with this
picture
as this climbed up and up and up pulling
back is fine we didn't pull back even in
this point very deep
but to pull back and to be shifting that
point of control lower um is very
unsettling when this happened i sat on
this trade and then as soon as we
started
to i was expecting at this point that we
would have broken through the initial
balance and then you know this was a
trade to really hold on to not to get
shaken out of
but
as we failed to just continue in these
rotations here just to push higher and
as we started breaking down um i bailed
on this kind of as we were dropping
and then
didn't know what to do with this we came
back to test view out very nicely still
didn't really know what to do with this
and then as this started dipping in this
was friday kind of getting late in the
session on friday
um i had no idea what was going on this
was a beautiful trend day i couldn't
imagine that this was coming all the way
back
this was such a massive drop i couldn't
feel good about getting back on the
lungs when we talk about using the
volume profile and looking for
repeatable patterns i had no repeatable
pattern here like this wasn't something
i was i was you know i'm used to seeing
and so i did nothing ended up not doing
anything else for the rest of the day
obviously this was a very nice morning
anyway
the point being here though is point of
controls shift throughout the day
quite often they don't mean anything or
they're not that valuable going back to
what i said at the very beginning
way more important than the point of
control shifting okay it's one thing to
see this why did that point of control
shift
that's a whole different story because
now the context here point of control is
shifting up as we trend
we pull back the point of control shifts
lower we're trading a lot at these lower
prices we're starting to like lower
prices again
something is odd about that picture
to
paint it and i can actually this would
potentially be helpful i have
let me pull up um
another example of this just quickly
all right so here's another example of a
day where we opened up started seeing
that trending type of behavior kind of a
couple double taps around that that
point of control before we really took
off
and we also had a incredibly deep
pullback and what we'll notice with a
situation like this
uh
as we push up we're starting to build up
some more volume the point of control
stays down there
as this builds out and as we pull back
the point of control does shift but we
shift it up
and then as the rest of this goes the
point of control stays there the point
of control doesn't shift any lower
and then we end up you know eventually
having that big run to the upside and
and
doing this actually the previous data
that i'm looking at it might be another
similar example a little bit more
difficult because i don't think that
there was
maybe good signs that this was just
going to blast off like that but i'm
sure if we draw a volume profile around
this
during all this action
where we have uh this you know liftoff
if the point of control shifts at all it
doesn't shift any lower okay and again
here this trending type behavior long
jagged profile this is what we would
expect and then uh you know this ends up
shifting one time at the very highs
but either way the overall idea being
there that
um
the overall idea
being that when the point of control
in a very specific situation
we identify that one side is control it
looks like this is a trending type of
environment
and
uh we're expecting that you know this is
going to be a trend day
the point of control shifts lower
something is wrong not to say that we we
can't revisit highs again or not even to
say that the the low is going to get
taken out
but whatever we're looking at here and
we would expect from trending behavior
uh
something's not right about that okay so
very powerful to see this because even
before this nasty thing happened here um
i i had a heads up that something was
wrong now
sometimes the information that we get
from profiling or from our method is not
always going to be a way that we can
profit but sometimes it's enough to just
help us understand something's not right
here and it can protect us in this case
i didn't know how to take advantage of
this drop um but at least it didn't turn
into a loss on me or you know remove
some of those things okay
so nice idea here just revolved around
point of control shift and again some of
those
rather particular details matter
because
pony control on a very balanced day
shifts down a little bit
very different piece of information and
i would not put that same weight on it
where i would totally change a trade
but in this exact situation that you
know that's something to keep your eye
on and that's an important piece of
information
okay probably all i have to say about
that uh that's that's good that's um
fascinating actually you know because i
do spend a lot of time on point of
controls within
in in order flow and you know when
point of controls are migrating up or
migrating down is very telling um
when moves can potentially be ending um
there was one question there about point
of controls um
question was would you say the point of
control from the previous session is
more or less important than the
developing point of control
really nice question okay would
definitely depend on context i'll
explain it like this in a situation
where
uh let's say like like this situation
okay here's that previous point of
control we never actually touched it
um
in this situation i'm actually not that
worried with this point of control at
all
because we opened up so far out of
balance
what we the balance that we did on this
day individually doesn't really matter
to me that much
so in a situation like this the
developing point of control was actually
way more important than this
now we flip that around and we open up
inside of yesterday's range instead of
opening up way down here better yet we
open up inside of yesterday's value
all of a sudden that previous point of
control becomes wildly important to me
and just like we're talking about
repeatable patterns here i have a whole
different repeatable pattern for what
happens when we open up in range in
value so the context but yeah in some
cases
this would be more important in some
cases this would be more important it's
such a nice question because
being able to wrap your mind around that
going back to what i said at the very
beginning
not so important what you're seeing a
naked point of control okay or a
previous point of control right we can
see those things easily
but to understand how they got there and
and what the context is around them
that gives us the power to understand
where we should be putting our
importance which is a different ball
game yeah
okay
cool
all right uh tally ho next one yep yep
okay
let's see here
um let me in case this might be our last
one so let me
this will be a little bit more i'll say
uh sophisticated this will be one that
is a little bit higher level
and this would uh i think challenge us
so this would be a nice one
what we're looking at here is um a very
balanced day i think a little bit
deceiving this is also
um this was
thursday i think last thursday so maybe
a week ago today this was actually a
live thing that you can go check out as
well
um
and what we did here is we opened up
inside the previous day's range and
value area okay so already setting the
tone for it being fairly balanced um we
revisited that previous point of control
okay in this environment they were very
close but you know this is a repeatable
thing we'll see happen
overall the the profile very balanced
quite ugly though where the point of
control was at the very extreme of that
value area um the way that we balanced
out was was i would say fairly ugly
but what we did is we opened up
big move away from the open okay pulled
back to the open couldn't get through it
this is a fairly confusing thing for me
because when i'm looking at the market
balancing out i'm very interested in how
we're treating the open when we start
pushing one side of the open especially
with some strings or if we can't get
through the open and we're just trading
one side um this is something where i
feel very uncomfortable fighting this
and and uh i'll typically be expecting
that one side's kind of taking over one
side's likely to be in control
in this situation there wasn't really
good signs that the shorts were
dominating but because of how we treated
the open it was fairly difficult for me
to expect that this was going to cross
through the open and actually be
balancing out for the day
so if i can turn these trades on
this is actually something that i sat on
for over the first hour of the day just
because i couldn't i was just getting
mixed information we're not
you know potentially one side's in
control they're just doing a horrible
job potentially this is going to find
some support eventually
what we ended up doing uh this also is
um
you know one of the trades you can check
out live but this isn't what i'm talking
about but this is a nice little
maybe additional insight
we're kind of doing this chopping around
thing volume somewhat dying off
and then we go through
this period of really
just this tight little consolidation
really tight it's a very specific kind
of pattern here where if you look around
you don't really see that surfacing
anywhere else just kind of an elongated
uh chop right here right at v-web
what we did is we broke out of this to
the downside and you can see the volume
kind of died off as that was forming
and then the volume picked up massive as
we pushed lower
as soon as this happened i'm dialed in
looking for shorts we broke out to the
downside i'm looking for this to
continue take out the low of day the
whole idea is forming
i'm waiting for some kind of a pullback
to get on board with instead of pulling
back and giving me an entry we pull all
the way back and take back this rotation
something to me something is wrong about
this we consolidated we broke out we
should not be back here if this is you
know going somewhere
so i flip the script look to get long
the thought being if we're not going to
break lower
looking for this to target higher
um if you're watching this in real time
i don't exactly know what happened we
consolidated here for a little while
longer and then in the blink of an eye
this move happened i blinked and all of
a sudden we were at the open
very similar to that first trade we
looked at when i told you that the news
kind of affected it and i just hit the
exit the same thing happened i just all
out hit the exit didn't really get
enough to scale here and then it just
popped me right to right to high
i just hit the exit
and then there was really no entry for
me to get back on board with this
now
where i want to focus in on was the
trade that was taken later in the day
here and what we'll see to kind of set
this up
is a day where we are balancing out
there needs to be some balance that is
forming
difficult read because of how we treated
the open but the general thing we'll see
this is the repeatable pattern we'll
open up we'll try higher we'll try lower
and then we'll extend out range one way
the way that we extend out that range
fails and we extend greater the other
way okay so kind of like an initial kind
of test what would have made this much
easier is a proper kind of push above
the open push below the open
kind of push above the open without
extending range and then doing this the
fact that we just held the open made
this a little difficult but the general
idea here of kind of testing higher
testing lower chopping around but not
extending out range extending out range
so we can have the initial chop we
extend out the range and then that that
chop gets taken back and we extend range
the other way
when this happens this sets up an
afternoon play um that if it surfaces is
very powerful
the idea is we extend out the range in
the the true direction that we're
heading for that day through all this
noise we are going this way
later in the session uh in the afternoon
this can't happen too late in the day
and we don't want to see this happen too
early too early being like
10 15 10 30
because we want to give this time to
properly understand that yeah this is
trying to break out of all this mess
we're going this way
and then it can't happen too late
because there's quite a bit more that
needs to happen once this sets up and if
it happens too late in the day the
chances that it sets up is low so the
way that this should happen is just
about here
around 12 o'clock somewhere in the
afternoon low eastern time we start
having a very deep pullback
that deep pullback takes us
right to the other side of value area
now if you're looking at this value area
is up here and we ended up dropping all
the way down
but what you don't see through this
static chart is what this all looked
like in real time
in real time
as we were pushing down into here
value area was not at the 73 value area
low was right here yeah and then this
was value very high this was the point
of control
so this push this has this balance we
try to extend range out one side this
side wins but not wins in the sense that
a trend is happening uh but one side is
is being fairly dominant
later in the afternoon we pull all the
way back get back inside a value area
and go all the way to the other side of
value
entering in the direction that we won
out of early in the morning
entering in that direction looking for
it to go coast to coast inside a value
so entered long
took the trade off just to mitigate risk
and then as this worked its way up um i
was really targeting the other side of
value area
the open had been such a weird price all
morning all day that as we pushed into
that open value area was just like six
ticks above
the old saying in trading don't be a
tick for a dick if i'm sitting here you
know down below 70 and we're you know
hitting 77
and i'm only looking for six more ticks
i'm i don't want to be in a position
where
we do something weird at the open and i
lose seven or eight points to try and
get six ticks and i think we'd all
understand that logic
so i like to trade in a tad early
we end up going to the other side of
that value and then we even end up
extending range out the other side um
this as a a secondary part where we
don't just go to the other side of value
but we actually keep extending the range
out
is also a very repeatable part of this
trade
this happened fairly recently and in the
environment that we're in right now i'm
having a fairly difficult time getting
trades to go all the way through to
completion i'm having a lot of
frustrations trying to read the action
very similar to the first trade we
looked at where i got chopped out of
that idea before it worked out you know
these things are happening in a little
bit higher quantity right now so overall
i've made some adjustments and i'm kind
of erring on the side of just the you
know exact targets you know even
something like this where it just shoots
me to something like the open instead of
waiting to see how it goes i just hit
the exit lock in gains you know be done
with it okay
yeah
i find that that opening price like on
directionless days days that aren't
going anywhere you tend to rotate around
opening price quite a bit
yes to me that's like a sign of
just stay out of the market until
something develops
but yes yes
i would feel the same exact way um
another thing that helps me a lot is how
we treat the overnight action which
we're not looking at the overnight but i
look at the overnight and i look at the
previous day's action as well and
something like this where we open up in
range in value especially if the
overnight is fairly balanced these are
some great signs that we're probably
going to be balancing out in the day
session
and then to see us chopping around the
open um it really reinforces that
and
a slight variation of this where we're
kind of just holding one side of the
open for the majority of the the morning
um you know kind of makes this whole
thing a bit of a difficult read
but it's a very nice example that we
don't always get these textbook versions
of things
and this is one of the i would say one
of the very difficult things about
trading
is
every single day it's kind of like a
snowflake it's just like there's no two
that are identical and this exact thing
that i described to you
will happen time and time and time again
but it likely will never shape up
exactly like this
so it's on us not to go out there half
cocked with information but to
understand we do need to learn these
things at you know at some level we
can't be confused about them we have to
have a level of competence
but we also have to have the ability to
make up for these small changes and then
in real time
be able to execute on these things and
that comes with time and that just comes
with
you know a level of competence with the
products you trade the markets that
you're involved with and one of the big
reasons why i'm so strong about
you know especially if you're profiling
learn one market learn one product uh
it'll help the learning curve go quite a
bit faster yeah do you find that certain
markets hold profiles better or
basically the same rules apply to all
markets
um yeah
products inside of futures virtually yes
markets in general like if we're talking
about
let's say penny stocks foreign
currencies
uh that aren't traded through urex
crypto you know if we're talking about
these type of markets um i would say
definitely not the reason being that we
rely on volume and we rely on that you
know what we're seeing here that creates
these patterns inside of something like
crypto the information is so bad like so
bad uh it's not what you're seeing is
different than what somebody else is
seeing right
it's a mess but with futures we're all
getting our data from you know virtually
exactly of course centralized data which
is important
it really makes it a superior market to
trade
if we're looking at things like future
profile yeah i agree 100
um there's an interesting question um it
says does a
level become stronger when the previous
value arial low and the developing value
area low are aligned so like in this
example
they are close
yeah really nice so
what i'll say to that
and i'll pull up um an additional
example because this will be
we can go back i think to maybe the
first thing we were talking about even
so if i turn this on we're not going to
be able to see this right now
these are some levels that are now
coming over from an additional chart
that i had so my part of the process for
every morning is i'll draw my levels of
of significance
and in this example
there's a very dark blue area here
and the reason this is a dark blue area
is because it is the close of the
previous day
it is the cutoff point that separates
these two distributions and it is also a
value area high for a micro composite
that i have
so a micro composite this is actually
going back several weeks ago we've
busted out of it to the high side and
then this is the most recently we've
pulled back
this move was the first time we pushed
back inside of this value area where the
value area high starts and you can see
we pushed into it
and then we held it yeah the next day we
came in and held it to the point being
here
that when we have multiple levels of
interest to me start to stack up
i always look at those as being more
important over uh previous close yeah
important level
cutoff point between distributions
important level value area high on a
microcomposite that we most recently
came back into and we're holding very
important
you stack all three of those are the
same exact price
let's really pay attention to this level
because now it's very important to me
yeah right right right so yeah to answer
that question if they start stacking up
yeah pay a little bit closer attention
to those for sure
oh that's great
great information
about you guys but i've been making a
lot of notes i got a whole page of notes
and stuff that i want to go away with
and
start looking at so
corpse
i know you
train traders right i i've
seen the reviews i've seen you know
people posted on chat boards etc that uh
that you've helped them
and honestly you know i know people have
been messaging me saying
you know they really want to get more
into volume profile because you know i'm
order flow and i deal a little bit with
volume pro 5 i really gone down the
rabbit hole on value within the within
um
the markets and to me that's really the
most important part of the markets is
value and
seeing the
profiles
obviously you're trading around value
right i mean we don't really think about
it but every day we go to the store
you know you're looking at you're
judging well should i buy this now or
should i buy when it goes on sale right
because you're trying to buy below value
and if it's too expensive you're not
gonna buy it so
it's it's one of those things so guys i
had been
talking to corpse because you know we've
been trying to get together to do this
for you guys for
for months and i said every time i talk
to corpse i always
pick up little little nuggets he doesn't
realize that you know for me it is great
because i get all this information i
have an access to him like that and i
know he does
take on um traders to work with him and
he's got like a a nice program and i got
him to give us
a special deal which is half off its
normal price i mean if you were to go to
his website and see it now this is not
his
his other program this is a
you know an all-in program right he's
really
gonna work with you almost on a
daily basis uh how often do you get
together with with people that you you
mentor
i think it's like what four times a week
or so something like that
yeah exactly so we'll do the the profile
formula which is a very intro product
and then the method which is what you're
talking about right now the volume
profile method that's my flagship
product like that's the main thing that
i do
um as far as that goes
we'll do
a live stream every single day
um except
saturday and uh sunday so monday through
friday we do live streams every day
we'll trade four days a week and then we
have two coaching calls which are just
times where i'll interact it'll be a
live call with me
these these are just set up in a way
that there's something you don't
understand about the the training
and if there's something that you're
struggling with while you're using it
we can come about it we can talk about
it we can look over the data and see
what's going on so okay i'm really
involved on that side i'm going to get
my screen back here for seconds um
oh such an aggressive picture of me
there
you know what i was looking for a nice
one uh no offense you got a lot of goofy
pictures online
[Laughter]
um
you know i saw something professional
but
yeah let me see here let me get my
screen up okay so
his
this is his volume sorry the profile
method and i'll just show you let me let
me just pull it up here let me get a
browser up here um because it's really
detailed on
the training what you'll go through here
so
i'll just get it up here
whoops where am i go up
uh so
12 months you know it's yeah i see a lot
of people they do mentoring and you know
it's just like a four-week
thing and you know honestly life gets in
the way sometimes and it's it's you know
then it's like you can't attend
everything so you know 12 months is a
bit of a commitment but you know you
want to make sure that
you're learning right and because
markets change i mean if you just look
at how the markets were
a year ago versus now
sometimes it looks completely different
you know some of these markets the
volatility has gone up a lot or it's
gone down so you know there's different
environments in the market and
you know trying to learn on
one environment then the environment
changes on you
you're screwed because you only know how
to trade one way so you know having a
longer
term you're going to be able to to learn
more so you know corbs offers
12 months access you get two time weekly
coaching calls right
four times a week live trading
pre-market prep workshop your live
streams you know you
that's where you're going to learn a lot
you know i do a weekly live stream and
you know people come in they ask
questions it's those live streams if you
can attend you know really
really help in
level up in your trade it's one thing to
watch videos but
you know when you're watching it you
know happening
unfold right before your eyes really
makes you know a big difference he's got
two chats what's the difference between
the market action and trade reviews chat
forbes
yeah so inside of our um the app that we
use to communicate there'll be market
action which is just stuff that's
happening currently and these are just
two different rooms inside the chat that
you'll have access to we also have just
a trade reviews channel this is where
you can post trades that you've taken
that you're satisfied with that you'd
like to share or trade that you've taken
that you're frustrated with that you
hope somebody can speak into and kind of
talk about where you went wrong yeah so
you get feedback basically from not just
you but from but from other people
because sometimes you know you took a
trade
and someone else took the opposite trade
so sometimes you know you'll run into a
situation so people say no you know i
saw this developing or i saw that
developing so it's you know it's
important to see that and
you know again guys this is
a
if you don't think that this is a good
deal i think you're out of your mind but
it's 2 900 okay for example if you were
to go look at
what is it here
if you go to the normal page okay
what you'd have to do is you'd have to
go through book a session
and it's going to be the full price 5
800 right you can see he's got reviews
here but
now you could get it for half the price
and it's actually got a split payment so
it's 2900 or you could do four payments
of 799.
and to be honest you know he showed you
a few trades just over the last couple
of days
right where you if even if you're
trading minis
or even micros you know you can start
recouping that back so i don't say in a
sense it's going to pay for itself but
at least you know you're going to see
these opportunities that you can take
advantage of
while you're still learning while you've
stretched out the payments you know me
i'm a big person on monthly you know if
i could split play stuff you know for my
own stuff that's over a certain dollar
amount i always think that's a good idea
so
again
you know i put the links in the chat
so check it out it's this is the link
here let me close this down
or
down here at the bottom
profilemethod.com coaching dash program
but again if you go through
the main website you're going to get
charged the full price so
i mean you could do that i mean i'm sure
he'll be happy to take your money but
honestly you're better off
saving the money
now
one of the things that corbs does
sort of on a daily basis or semi-daily
basis is he has his
um what's it called plan of attack and
you know he sort of goes through the you
know
how to get prepared for the day and
you know he's been gracious enough to
allow us to share it with you and
the link is there in the chat but if you
were to go
type it in just orderflows.com corbs you
can see he's got a video on how to do it
this is his you could download the exact
template well this is his pre-market
prep but he's got the template here the
plan of attack
template where you're going to go
through it's a two-page thing um
and you make your notes get ready so
what do you got to say about this uh
corpse i mean i thought it was a big
help for some traders i i did watch
um a few of your videos and some of the
traders were commenting on that
but this is something you go through
every day yeah
yeah i think one of the one of the
biggest issues is just creating
structure for yourself as a trader
because we have walked into some of us
not even knowing it very much a
entrepreneurial endeavor here
and um it's on us to be organized it's
on us to have processes in place and if
you ever find yourself where you're kind
of sitting down at the computer in the
beginning of the day and you don't
really know what you're doing you think
maybe
um you have to think about what should i
be doing next i would suggest that
you're very lost in the process and and
there's no way that that's really going
to translate into you performing well
that day so having just a set structure
that you follow day in and day out that
you can start refining and that you can
stick to it makes trading more efficient
and it helps us behave more like
professionals as opposed to just kind of
doing whatever we want that day of
right right yeah i mean that's the thing
it's like you know every trading book
you read says oh you gotta have a
trading plan and stuff but at the end of
the day there's nobody holding you
accountable to it um you know but
having
it say he said you go online you could
download hundreds of different you know
trading plan oh this is my training plan
like this but watch the the video that
corbs made for you on that page um you
know on how he goes through it and how
you're supposed to do it because you
know again it's one of those things
where it sounds basic but a lot of
people don't do it they don't follow up
on it and as a result
trading suffers right you need to have
some structure
in your day in your trading day um
you know it's not like markets open up
at you know 8 30 i'm in chicago so it's
8 30 the cash opens it's not like
turning on your computer at 825 and
sitting down you know you you should
have some
view of the market you know how it did
yesterday and you know how it's trading
you know coming into the cash open
things like that you know what can
affect the market so
that's you know the whole beauty of
having a plan of attack
one other question um
does it matter what trading platform
like sierra charge i think you're
showing us your charts but can be used
with ninjatrader as well
yeah for sure we actually have some
custom stuff built out for a ninjatrader
as an option any charting package that
has good profiling capabilities is fine
and ninjatrader or sierra work excellent
okay okay one other question last
question here
what is the best time frame do you
recommend for intraday for volume
profile
um depends a little bit on the product
you're trading but i would uh if you're
talking about time frame as far as what
hours to trade is that how i'm wearing
that
yeah i mean it's yeah john
i see your question there it's
because the profile if you're looking at
you know the profile will develop over
the course of days so whether you look
at a one minute chart or a eight minute
chart or something you know it's going
to develop the same way it's really your
sort of your your trigger chart your
entry chart that you're going to base
your entries off of i think is
um yeah exactly these are slightly
different things to where the reason you
would change around your time frame is
not going to be because of the analysis
of the trading of the profile that would
be more on the trading side of things
when you're looking to enter or if
you're looking to refine that down i'm
kind of like what i said the very
beginning the difference between the
analysis and you know actual trading
right right right okay so again you know
time frame
chart type again you know some people
like tick based charts some like range
based charts um corbs uses a point and
figure chart i use
time based chart it really comes down to
a little bit i think on your style of
trading and
because i said the profile is going to
develop the same whether you're looking
at a range based chart or a
you know a time based chart or a point
figure chart i mean the profile for the
day it's just
your
trigger chart your entries and and where
you can be judging your exits from in my
opinion
yeah very preferential there's there's
not not a real
set thing that has to happen there yeah
yeah i get it i get it all right guys
you know i don't keep you guys any
longer i know it's still thursday some
of us got to get back to work
um i know i know corbyn's i think he got
an afternoon session today as well so
you know i'll leave it there yeah guys
you got any questions you'll put them in
the chat or you could you know email me
everyone's got my email you could uh
it's my get order flows and you know
we'll do our best to get back to you so
again thanks for your time today corpse
i know it's uh
it's always a pleasure talking to you
honestly i i do i got a few ideas
running through my head already that i
wanted to go test out and see
so i hope everybody got some
good
good thoughts in their brain you know
some gold nuggets i know i did so thanks
again guys for coming out today and
again thanks corbs for uh taking time
out of your schedule to join us
oh you got it mike pleasure was all mine
i could uh talk about this all day any
day every day so be well and uh happy
trading to everybody if you're gonna be
on the screens rest this afternoon
thanks for having me all right bye-bye
you